but I like this ring so Allison Williams
your co-star that she gave you a bit of
a complex on says she didn't it was the
makeup woman she's cool but she took him
out like the kitchen in it like yes I
was the kissing scene I don't know if
you guys I don't know maybe he said that
word in England does this yeah the kiss
is seen and then just before it they
would give me like cool I I didn't know
I had my co actor suddenly just before
was seen with that they came up and gave
a mint and I didn't know if I was gonna
take it as a like a nice thing to do or
is it just like oh my god he thinks my
breath is and we did a number taste give
me another minute that was worth an
issue didn't took me for the rest of day
because I was out why giving me mints so
in England we don't do that nope no just
method
Australia mid snow means no it was a
thing that I discovered in America I was
like wow my friends very considerate
that what's worse than the mince is
someone I'm not going to name names
because um spit someone that I had to
kiss insisted that before every kiss
either he or I had to put Neosporin on
our lips was not what's that really it's
kind of like an ointment an
antibacterial ointment or something to
heal what like it's it's something you
put on like people put it around their
noses when they fly so they don't get
sick it's not fast lean it's got it's
it's a it's like a Vicks
oh is it a big hand sanitizer no it's
it's called neosporin and I need to put
it on the lips so you don't pass any
germs or anything it was really I guess
something I didn't know that one time
apparently is bad etiquette to put your
tongue you know I didn't know that
[Applause]
I wasn't doing it because I thought we
keepin it real party if you fancy them
you put your tongue in yeah that's what
someone told me another Shh early on
thankfully like don't stress about it
but no tongue and I was like oh got it I
always said it to other people I'm like
yeah it's so cool but like no tongue but
why wouldn't someone tell you that why
wouldn't wait you're like someone should
have told you that before you put the
tongue no but this is like years later
conversation said you not supposed to be
your tongue you know was that what to
say and I think it's really great advice
for for actors because you got kissing
tips from a great Allison one of the
greatest yeah one of the greatest Meryl
Streep I had to kiss in a movie called
the hours and she was not happy with the
way a certain scene was being lit and we
had to kiss and she said I'm going to do
you a favor you're gonna thank me for it
later can I demonstrate on you AMI
yeah of course you can yes please oh no
Thomas
[Applause]
pineapple all right the cameras would
let that one's probably that's our cover
right there okay so you know so I have
these of nasal nasal labial folds I call
them these here and they look better
with her pull back so she came in to
kiss me and she went like this that's
what she did for me and it did actually
she pulled my face back and kiss me and
it was it so you can go watch the movie
it's very funny to see that no I really
want you to win the Oscar it's like a
kiss to
[Music]
you